แนวคิดเรื่อง fundamentalist นั้นเชื่อมโยงกับ
แนวคิดเรื่องการวัดในกลศาสตร์ควอนตัมอยู่
ก่อนที่กลศาสตร์ควอนตัมจะถูกพัฒนาขึ้น
นักวิทยาศาสตร์ต่างรู้กันดีว่า
ถ้าระบบอยู่ในสถานะที่กำหนดชัดเจน
ระบบนั้นจะอยู่ในสถานะหนึ่ง
และถ้าวัดค่ามัน ก็จะได้
ผลลัพธ์ที่ชัดเจน แต่ในกลศาสตร์ควอนตัม
มันไม่เป็นแบบนั้นอีกต่อไป ระบบอาจอยู่ใน
สถานะที่กำหนดชัดเจนอย่างสมบูรณ์แบบ
แต่เมื่อทำการวัดบางอย่าง
ผลลัพธ์ที่ได้กลับเป็นแบบสุ่ม
เพื่อให้เห็นภาพแนวคิดนี้ชัดขึ้น
ต้องพูดถึงแนวคิดเรื่อง superposition ก่อน
superposition ไม่ใช่แนวคิดที่แปลกใหม่แต่อย่างใด
มันขึ้นอยู่กับระบบที่แสดง
การซ้อนทับเชิงเส้นของหลายสถานะ
ในเวลาเดียวกัน ลองนึกถึง
คลื่นวิทยุที่ประกอบด้วย
ความถี่หลายแบบพร้อมกัน ไม่มีอะไร
ที่ขัดกับหลักฟิสิกส์เลย
สิ่งที่ทำให้ superposition มีกลิ่นอายควอนตัมคือ การวัดระบบ
นั่นเอง
ขอยกตัวอย่างให้เห็นภาพ
ลองนึกว่ามีระบบของลูกศร
และเราเตรียมระบบนั้น
ให้ลูกศรทุกอันชี้ไปทางซ้าย
แล้วเราก็ไปถาม
ระบบว่า "แกชี้ขึ้นหรือลง?"
ทีนี้ เพราะลูกศรที่ชี้ซ้ายสามารถ
อธิบายได้ว่าเป็น
superposition ของ
ขึ้นกับลง เราก็จะได้
ผลลัพธ์ที่ห้าสิบเปอร์เซ็นต์ขึ้น
และห้าสิบเปอร์เซ็นต์ลง เมื่อถามว่าชี้ขึ้นหรือเปล่า
นั่นคือผลลัพธ์ที่ได้จากระบบ
แล้วลองเตรียม
ระบบในสถานะต่างออกไป โดยให้
ลูกศรครึ่งหนึ่งชี้ขึ้น และครึ่งหนึ่งชี้
ลง แล้วถามคำถามเดิม
ผลลัพธ์ก็ยังเหมือนเดิม
ทั้งที่สองระบบต่างกันมาก
แต่ได้ข้อมูลเหมือนกัน
มาตลอด
แล้วจะรู้ได้ยังไงว่าต่างกันตรงไหน?
ระบบทั้งสองต่างกันมาก
เพราะในกรณีแรก เราเตรียมระบบไว้ใน
สถานะบริสุทธิ์ ซึ่งหมายความว่า
มีคำถามที่ถามระบบแล้วได้คำตอบแบบ deterministic
ไม่ใช่แบบสุ่ม คือถามว่า "ชี้ซ้ายหรือขวา?"
มันจะตอบว่าซ้ายร้อยเปอร์เซ็นต์
ในกรณีที่สอง ไม่มีคำถามใดที่ถามได้
แล้วจะได้คำตอบร้อยเปอร์เซ็นต์ เพราะมันเป็น mixture
ผลลัพธ์จึงไม่ชัดเจน เพราะมันคือ mixture
ดังนั้นถ้าถามซ้ายหรือขวา
ก็จะสุ่ม เพราะครึ่งหนึ่งชี้ขึ้น
อีกครึ่งชี้ลง ถ้าถามขึ้นหรือลง
ก็เหมือนกัน จะได้ห้าสิบเปอร์เซ็นต์
แล้วสิ่งนี้เกี่ยวกับความสุ่มยังไง?
ลองนึกดูว่า
คล้ายกับการโยนเหรียญ ก็จะได้หัวหรือก้อย
แต่ไม่เหมือนการโยนเหรียญทั่วไปเลย
เพราะตอนที่โยนเหรียญ
สาเหตุที่เราไม่รู้ผลล่วงหน้า
ก็เพราะเราไม่รู้
พลังงานที่ใช้โยน มุมที่หมุน
สภาพแวดล้อมในห้อง
และอื่นๆ อีก ถ้ารู้ตัวแปรพวกนั้น
ก็คำนวณได้ว่าจะออกหัวหรือก้อย
ตัวแปรพวกนั้นซ่อนอยู่จากผู้สังเกต
และนักวิทยาศาสตร์หลายปีคิดว่ามี
ตัวแปรที่คล้ายกันซ่อนอยู่ในกลศาสตร์ควอนตัมที่
ปรากฏออกมาในรูปของความสุ่ม
และมันก็ไม่ใช่จนกระทั่ง
ผลงานสำคัญของ John Bell ในยุคหกสิบ ที่พิสูจน์ว่า
นั่นไม่เป็นความจริง
และตอนนี้นักฟิสิกส์ทุกคน
ยอมรับว่าไม่มี
ทฤษฎีตัวแปรซ่อนเร้นที่เข้ากันได้กับกลศาสตร์ควอนตัม
มันเป็นเรื่องจริงที่ว่าเมื่อวัดระบบ
ธรรมชาติจะสุ่มขึ้นมา
ไม่ว่าจะคิดนานแค่ไหนก็ตาม
มันยังน่าทึ่งมากสำหรับฉันอยู่ดี